我录一下 谢谢 我今天早点开始
然后 昨天有些新闻
其实我这个Printation可能是周末准备的
然后 昨天有些新闻没有挠过进去
就是在乌兹姆斯海峡又开始就是互相放脑袋
然后我觉得 其实上一周的时候
我们做过一些对于市场的风险的提示
然后这个主要是在于我看仓卫方面
就是在CTE没有买牌
然后有大量的Mense and Rebalance
就是月末的这个品牌卖出来
但是市场其实处于一个非常割裂的状态
我当时可以给大家展示一下
就是这个割裂在于 我觉得现在市场还是非常割裂的
这个割裂在于宏观市场
包括利率 油价
其实昨天晚上开始 利率的波动率
就是Interest Revolt
然后 这个就是相当于是比较负面
然后另外一方面 我们看到银行接待流动性
我们看到散户吧
其实特别是我觉得大部分交易
Leverage ETF都是retail比较多吧
就是retail flow加上Leverage ETF的这个买牌
比较积极的冲到市场上去
市场上有非常割裂的这个投资
我们一方面看到Leverage ETF买了很多
另外一方面 我们看到Prime Book
就是对冲基金在大量的卖出
所以这个市场 一方面就是大型市场
宏观和微观的巨大的隔离
然后宏观是真实的
宏观上面油价的这个影响
和油价对经济体本身的影响
现在没有显现出来
我们看到的 我一点点讲吧
就是我们看到的可能是表面上的这个价格上涨
真正的我们叫做demon destruction
还没有开始
所以我们看到了宏观上的这些危机都是真实的
然后利率上升
因为油价的上升
其实这个东西很多都是油价带出来的
然后甚至油价如果马上回去
这是一个沟门的预期
就是说即使油价马上回去
Bassline的这个 oil price
就是不油价马上回去
即使这个海峡马上开放
Bassline的这个油价也没有办法跑回去的
所以这个我们看到油的确实和油价带动后面
可能会产生GDP的下降
可能会产生需求demon destruction
需求的下降
然后可能会产生通胀的影响
甚至通胀影响在上周的时候
我们看FOMC的会议的时候
其实已经对FOMC的Member造成了一些影响
我们看到三个委员已经相对来说
变得更加中心
所以这个宏观上是真实的
另外一方面
我们说一下微观的
然后微观上其实也是真实
就是市场过去很长时间
没有去定价计算能力提高
直接等于生产力
所以这个我说的长一点
20年了吧
那个从互联网革命到现在
虽然我们的芯片一直在迭代
然后但是芯片的迭代迈到这手机上
其实你说你iPhone每一代
能够插多少手机客户用户是有差别的
但是它没有直接变成生产力
所以这个和就是在互联网芯片上的革命
在过去几十年里面
它和比方说蒸汽机的革命
和内燃机的革命是不一样的
你蒸汽机的功率上升了
你是直接能够多产衣服的
你的电力提高在1920世纪初的时候
你是直接变成生产力
所以技术革命并没有直接过去变成生产力
但是现在因为延远
然后半导体的革命或者半导体的制成的提高
把制成提高加上经验封邦的这个提高
就是所有提高算力的东西
都是直接变成了生产力
那个这个大家体会应该是很深的
你现在用一下那个5.5
你觉得5.5已经比4.7好用了
就比那个就GPD5.5已经比Cloud4.7好用
所以这个在微One层层面上面的半导体的需求
我觉得也是真实的
只是市场现在忽然开始意识到这个问题
然后使得半导体在我们说这一轮
在超级的这个周期里面一下子疯狂的上场
然后转器里面确实是有胖感
也有很多的问题
但是我觉得即使在现在这个价位上
半导体的需求也没有完全反映出
它后面不停的迭代
然后导致它不停的需求的增加
然后导致它生产力的提高
这个我觉得这个loop并没有完全
不用没有完全被定价
市场还是非常不喜欢
过去英文20年
我们的生产模式的变化
所以市场还是非常不喜欢
Havocapax就是我们叫做高中资产投入
但是未来因为你的技术是和生产力
直接挂过的
我们之前讲过药厂模式和工厂模式
所以当你走路工厂模式的时候
你就是要不停的采购工厂设备
当你工厂设备提高的时候
它变成直接变成生产力
你就是要不停的采购半导体
所以半导体我觉得这个大的周期并没有走完
短的周期不好受
短的周期可能是几个星期一个月之类
这么短的周期不太好受
你觉得短期里面你已经 overpriced
那我说到 overpriced 有点像我们当年
我讲到 Intel overpriced 一样
我好像在58之前说它 overpriced
最后没有卖
我卖了然后又卖回来了
然后58块钱 overpriced
但它确实在那个时点是 overpriced
就是过渡定价
但你要说对于这整个公司的长线的固执
后面的价值没有体现
一样半导体也没有体现出来
没有完全体现
但是短期里它肯定有 overpriced
有点过渡定价
所以我从油价开始说
开始先说一下宏观
然后宏观上面来说
你们可以看
就是这次油价上升的深远的影响
或者它影响恶劣的程度
是比上一次额污染这样严重了多的
甚至比1973年还要严重
就是如果它维持更长时间
1973年是由经济没有维持特别长时间
现在Stalmate就是两边的这个僵局
没有看到有很好解决方案
那这个我们前几次一直说过油价
我觉得一些主要的数据
大家可以我写的下面
你们可以关注一下
就是对于海峡10%的油价的影响
10%的油价影响是0.1GDP
是0.04的PCE
虽然Kaman Wash可能不是完全看PCE
但是我们NPC来核算
就是核心PC CorePC0.04
然后PCE的话0.02
这个帮我写错了
0.02不是0.02
然后这个小一个零
然后但是这一次对于点贸Destruction
就是你现在的感受是价格是少什么
但是需求并没有减少
因为大家还在用很多的商业储存储存油
然后还有国家储存储存战略储存油
占储的油现在在中国
在美国都被放出来
然后商业存的油和存的材料现在再被释放
但是到了5月份6月份
当这一部分的组成油开始变得更加少的时候
我们必须要经历一次实际的需求减少
这个需求减少就是很痛苦的
对比你像比方说现在存储价格在涨
就是指质涨价格
它没有产生那个需求减少
在去年年底的时候
那个存储价格涨是直接产生需求减少
所以你看到Kensumera穿上来的供不了货了
然后那个调自价钱在上
花钱被炒了好几倍
比现价高好几倍
那现在跌下来了
那么这些就是需求减少
需求减少的痛是更加痛
所以我是觉得油价现在继续进入Stelmate
那么这个更加的痛就可能会到来
然后即使不进入Stelmate
就是今天马上开放
它在过去一段时间
对于供应面的这个supply side destruction
也需要好几个月升值大半年
然后才能恢复
所以油价的影响是很深远的
就这个事情
而且是比较恶劣的
在宏观上
昨天的习近平
因为已经一个多月停火了
然后又袭击了有意义
那个伊朗又袭击有意义
美国还没做出特别激进的这个反应
会不会做
我觉得华盛顿现在正在评估这件事情
就是我把这个毒瘤留在那里
慢慢去限制它
还是我到底要采取什么激进的措施
这个事情华盛顿我觉得还在
现在还在做决定
那么假设它这个Stelmate没有办法结束
那么对于美联储的影响
你想Powell在上一次会议的时候
on hold
但是比较让人意外的是vote变少了
就是有四个vote
现在更趋向于更加硬盘
J-Pow没有
虽然它是离开了Fat Chairman
这个很搞笑
他是人家问他
你离开了Fat Chairman
然后你现在做中间一个搞完的
做一个行长
那么你在美联储以后要干嘛
他就把头低下来说
我低下头
但是其实这也是对特朗普的一个
对Trump一个无声的抗议
你的那个Leagoloss还没有给我结束
所以我还在那里面恶心你
他以前是千门
现在Fat是非常descent
就是非常分裂的
对于通常这性非常分裂
Cabin Wash准备用的那个
叫做Million and Mean的PCE
就是通常
就是我的通常并不是用到
一般的通常
我是要把最大的那个变化
和最小变化去掉
用中间那一块
但是中间那一块的话
其实在短期里面
先把石油去掉
把石油去掉
其实在它上台以后
你可以看
这是给我们的预计
就核心PCE的话
把那个Tariff去掉的话
它其实比现在用的PCE要更低一点
那么其实是有利于它
可以去做降息的
但是因为有加
它会影响到利率的政策
然后而且现在连处非常分裂
J-PAL还在里面没有走
那么Cabin Wash有多大能力推动连处
用连处是个投票机制
你需要Fat千万有足够的影响力
像J-PAL是有足够的影响力
包括以前的Balanki到言论
他们都是有足够的影响力
去推动去推票
他们的决策机制往往并不是说
我在最后那次会议上面
大家去投票
而在会议之前
大家都会经过
sure out的这个
就是非常仔细的讨论
然后进入会议的时候
其实已经知道大家会怎么vote了
就是但是这个样子
但是这个对于你的吹票能力要求是很高的
那么J-PAL在里面
不管它什么态度
它在里面
然后连处现在比较分裂
所以Cabin Wash能不能推动去降息
不太好说
它本身它的形象也是个硬盘
然后我是觉得
它有可能会象征性的做一些QT
有可能
但是它的agenda
它的目标肯定是要去
因为Trump一直叫J-PAL叫too late
所以它的agenda是会想去降息的
但是推动的力量
因为油价
因为这个通胀的预期开始上升
所以油价在短期的上涨
它不会对通胀长期预期有特别大的影响
但是如果像现在又放那个导弹
然后大家进入Stell Mate
不知道一个月还是两个月
这个油价可能推到了120
我觉得可能推到150以上
如果一两个月的话
那么这个对通胀预期就是真的有影响
然后毁灭了需求
对通胀预期有影响
让连处其实很难做
同时的话
我们看到上周
我这边没有数据
没有放
就是昨天晚上
其实利率市场有很大的波动
30年利率超过5
这30年利率不是一个很好的参考
但是10年期利率
4.46好像是
仅仅4.5
这个也是一个非常危险的信号
然后10年期利率的波动率在上升
所以我刚刚讲到的就是
宏观层面的危险信号
在多方维度下再累计
就是这个一般来说
你可以看
就是我们不能说表说
因为微玩上为什么会涨
微玩上为什么会涨
因为ETF的买盘
你知道上一周对于3米ETF的买盘
最多的一天达到9别人刀了
就是有91美元
91美元的rebalance的这个奥德
就是我rebalance奥德是什么意思
就是我这边加杠杆去买这个ETF
ETF这三倍做多
所以它在涨的时候
它自己rebalance就是要去
更多的去买ETF
retailing less的大规模再买这个东西
所以你在推动整个3米
这个图可能并不是上一召
但是基本上你看到的状态
也是差不多样子
就是大量的人再买加杠杆的ETF
所以很难说
你说一定说下一周能够把这个市场怎么样
你这个莫曼腾是不是还在
因为毕竟大家很认可
现在开始很认可
就是我刚刚讲的从工厂的模式
从半导体工厂模式
所以在经济不确定的情况下
你有很多行业都不确定
包括软件
我们过了软件这个PACE
在过去20年里面
软件都是像收税一样的
就是我发明我做一个软件
它是药厂是收税模式
那这个模式其实从怎么说呢
从很大程度上也主导了
欧洲和美国的经济托时就续
因为大家都不喜欢HavocapX
都喜欢软件
都喜欢设计
都喜欢做轻的模式
所以这个使得很多经济体
托时就续也有很大原因
但是现在要续续就实了
因为回过头来
我做的所有的AN
我每次问它的问题都是有成本
都是背后都是半导体
都是电到半导体
到它回答问题都有成本
所以又会变回工厂
那这个过程当中很多的资金
其实我们上一周看到了
那个real money的买盘
是过去几年里面最大的
然后看到了ETF的卖盘非常的大
但是同时的话
我说在宏观层面上
对冲基金在做空
然后利率在不确定性
然后油价在上升
甚至我们对通胀也不是那么决定
我本来觉得今年要加两次息
今年如果说是有三个委员在上一次会议
会议中间更加屈性于不驱动的话
那其实降息的空间我觉得就还是
就相当于可能就一次
或者会变得更小
就是我们叫room to cut
就会变得更少一点
然后昨天甚至在利率全面上升的时候
短期利率还定价了要升息
但是我觉得升息不可能
因为我就说
我之前讲过一个
就是如果你想去超底
然后你想去超底
对于于伊朗的危机结束这种级别的超底
你可以去等利率的时候去超利率
就是等市场开始pricing
它要衰退
所以我们在3月底3月底4月初
看到这一轮的反弹
那这一轮反弹一方面是CTA带动
就CTA买盘到那位置卖不动了
因为估值很低
本质上大家对于Oppos 4.6出来
到GPD5.5出来
大家认为AI已经确定的
可以新型生产力了
然后半导体已经确定的变成生产力了
所以这个过程中你不一定砸到洞
然后CTA带动它的买盘
把它买上去
包括把3B买上去
但是这危机过去
从开战开始到现在这危机没有过去
它他口没有用
就是这个东西没有完全过去
所以我们看到之前说到的利率
并没有到一个超底的位置
就是现在在昨天市场
利率市场的定价还是定价要继续打仗
然后我们看到宏观和危观的很大的分歧
所以宏观和危观有很大分歧的时候
市场有一种走法就跟上一周一样
就是整个指数可能没有涨多少
或者是接下去可能指数要跌一下
但是在半导体上
它的半导体上可能它未必有跌了太多
然后在某一些半导体的小的subsector里面
可能还跌不动
还要继续涨
所以我们在上两周看到的
那个上两周看到的market
market就市场的这个宽度
市场宽度是什么意思呢
就是哪些股票在涨
那整个sector里面只有Semicut在涨
这个半导体在涨
主要是半导体在拉动
然后我觉得在接下去一段时间里面
整个市场的skillness会变得更大
就是那个skill会变得更加skill
就是变成skill更加偏斜
涨执掌很少的股份
就是股票指数不一定会跌或者怎么样
就是这个有宏观方面的很大的不确定性
但是涨的股票的数量会变得更少
就是今年我其实包括我在我们办公室里面
问了一下同事
然后其实大部分同事还是亏钱
有很多同事还是亏钱
是这样子
就是其实这是市场的一个常态
也就今年你看到有很多投资是赚了很多钱
你今年只要是在我们三月份底
说到三月底的时候
我说到要去买三米
就是我到处在说要全仓三米的时候
如果你进去今年就是40%
那你觉得赚了很多钱
但是如果没在那个时间进去
你没有买到甚至你没有买三米
那么今年的Performance就一塌糊涂
这个trend会继续下去
宏观补确定性还是很大的
但是微观上的就是我讲的就是
token当每年4倍的增加
而且这个token的增加背后带动的是真实的需求
因为它的真实的需求是
我不管怎么样
比方说我现在不管怎么样
用5.5更贵了
用那个GPD5.5去做很多口音
它比人要便宜的多
它让我可以砍掉人
就是人砍掉
然后需求变少
经济变差
那是再下一轮的故事
但是就现在当前的故事
至少是可以把人砍掉
它肯定是别人便宜
所以而且当我用选择
用4.7还是用5.5的时候
因为我们做很多Trading相关的
那个我们是立马能检测
就是我下单速度多少
这些立马能检测
所以当我们在做这些事情的时候
效果马上能检测
我对于Token的价格是没有敏感性
我觉得很多做Program的都是这样子
就是对Token价格
因为它比人已经便宜太多了
而且我肯定是追寻
追寻它的准确度啊
这效果
我对Token价格没有很大的敏感性
所以宏观和微观的割裂还会继续
但是在宏观和微观割裂继续的时候
往往是市场相对来说比较危险的时候
就是我们Recall一下我们上周讲
上周讲的是
当你在三个星期回顾看最早一个月以前
3月31号之前的那个星期
那一个月卖出1800亿CTA
然后在第一个星期买了400亿
整个指数爆炸
结果接下去一个星期买了800亿
我们说Global CTA买了800亿
指数涨了一部分百分之四百分之五
接下去在这个星期
就是到上上个星期
上上星期和上上星期
上上星期买硬买买200亿
这个都是强制性的买卢
而且是不管涨界都要买的
所以买了200亿
让这个指数维持在那个位置上
因为维持住了
所以上星期大量Retail的钱
Long only的钱
然后加上杠杆的钱又冲进来
然后把特别是三米克纳特半导体
再推上去再涨了一波
后面有没有钱的
后面CTA不会买
这个不是那么重要
就不是那么重要
没有强制性的买卢
然后Hyperscalor的业绩过调了
Hyperscalor给出了很明确的指引
就是我哪怕FreeCashflow是负的
或变了不是很好
很高
但是我还是要继续要去做这个CAPEX
然后所以对半导体推动又是很大
就上周的对配半导体推动很大
那么接下去
几周有一些半导体公司
包括明天有AMD
有好像GlobalFundry什么的
有一些半导体公司会报一些而已
那么再之后
宏观和微观的博弈会在谁显现更大力量
我觉得是宏观力量
所以当你是一个有很大的杠杆的投村的时候
然后你对的是宏观的危机
你在短期里肯定会调整
就是这个我是对半导体的投资人的一个看法
但是半导体投资人
哪怕你被调整到
我觉得也没有关系
我也有投存
就是我手上也有半导体
然后我有诺基
然后也有AMD
然后我是不太会动
就是我是不太会动的原因是
因为我操作表情
然后第二呢
就是我觉得这个半导体是有更长周期的
你手上如果有存储啊光啊
我觉得这都调整不调整都无所谓
因为你知道的就是这个赛道和过去十年
是确实是不一样
过去十年你做的半导体做了多精细
你是变成手机多精细
然后真正的利润是被在手机上做APP的人给拿走了
做软件的人要做
然后他们获得了比方说你他做游戏
他赚了钱
但是这个东西不是半导体
不是直接生产生产生产地
现在是直接生产生产地
也就是anthropic和OpenAI的竞争
你最后还是要回到谁卡多
Large language model这个东西
现在就是scaling law
然后后面要做infra
又是直接是卡
所以卡这个东西呢
就是安老体的这个现在是春天
大家去春天
春天会有到春海
接下去可能会有到春海
但是没有这个长周期是很长的
就是他对于token的需求的长周期是很长
因为这个token是直接
我刚刚讲直接生产生产地
然后我说一下我当年底的一个
我觉得可能当年底要有人更加长一点的调整
那我刚刚讲的是战术层面
也就是现场市场仓位
因为你这边都是钢砍盘
然后primebook三个standard deviation
primebook连续两周
三个standard deviation
三个方差的做作控是非常
非常积极在那做
但是这个是非常短期的
相当于是战术型
然后我补充一个
就是为什么还有这两周市场能够这样涨
另外一个原因就是流动性很好
financial conditions index
就是我们叫高盛的financial conditions
FCM
然后过去一年你可以看这个
总的是红颜色线
对于equity对股票的话是这条线
所以它还是流动性再变好
然后我们其实去年
去年预期过这件事情
就是在四月份以后
因为监管放松各方面的原因
会让流动性变得非常好
那么包括在二季度之前的发债量
net发债量也比较低
所以整个都比较支持在
二季度之前流动性很好
其实银行间的钱很不缺
就是为什么能够杠杆盘
杠杆这样换
就是我其实觉得上周本来市场
就应该调整
然后当然上周市场没有怎么调整的原因
我觉得银行间的钱还是比较多的
至少到二季度之前
银行间钱很多
红弯的风险是一个问题
但银行间钱很多
你们可以看一个
就是昨天我没有仔细看
昨天应该市场变化
但是tempremium减去swap spread
tempremium减swap spread是个什么
就是相当于我在银行里面养劝
我养的是短期短期tempremium
tempremium等于我拿短期的利率
去养长期的劝
然后我养长期的劝
因为我的成本肯定不是trash rate
不是国债
我的成本是swap
是software
所以我养劝用的是software rate
我等于是tempremium减swap spread
这个东西是我养劝的真正的收益
这个收益十年期大概只有二十几个点
也就是谁花
就这个市场波动我要不要不保证金
然后我十年期利率波动
永远不值得
就是我赢了十年期利率的波动
我愿意只收二十五个basis point
以内的钱
然后至少上信息
然后去养这个圈
说明银行的流动性已经多到翻岸
就是银行间的流动性多到翻岸
这个我们在上几周也讲到过这问题
包括讲到software rate的低于
就是银行借的接待利率
低于美联储的repo rate
这个也发生过
对吧
就上上周也发生过
所以四月份之后
这个流动性确实很多
你说这个流动性会不会继续很多
我确实也没有经历过
有人直接把那个
直接把那个
这个 risk based capital和那个
这个资本金要求的比率同时调整
然后让银行间多出几千亿的
这个capital的钱的这个情况
我没有碰到过这样
然后高盛之前给过预期嘛
四万亿嘛
我今天多说几句
然后高盛之前给过预期嘛
四万亿
整个银行间可以多承受的资产量
所以我没有经历过这样规模的
相当于去监管的方钱
然后对于financial conditions
到最后会放出多少钱
我也不太清楚
这我们只能胜为待
所以我们说的是在宏观和危管层面
包括宏观层面也有利多
就是那个
financial conditions
就是整个流动性肯定是利多的
所以石油通胀
美联储政策这些是利空的
所以他们处于一个非常纠结的状态
那么在短期里面刚感比较高
我觉得是属于高位
但是真正的我觉得会有一波调整
因为我们说到半脑体的周期
是一个年伪计
数年伪计的一个周期
也是非常看好
但是在这过程中间
我觉得会有一次比较大的调整
然后这个比较大调整
其实要边走边看
你也很难在现在界定它什么时候
我初步觉得可能今年年底
今年年底或者明年初要有一次
然后这个比较大调整
可能要几个月
然后经历几个月
为什么
就是现在市场越来越担心的是
funding
就是你钱从哪里来
你们可以看到
就是这个事情也讲过很多次了
就是半脑体
就是大的hyperscale
不管它freak out
就变少
变少了多少
他们非常清楚
他们是排腻
就是我今天不投工厂
就相当于我原来是做药厂
我现在不投工厂
不投工厂
我这公司完蛋
在那个AI时代我就完蛋
因为整个模式会改变
但是从排腻的认知
就是hyperscale
那几个大的互联网科技公司
他认知是非常超前
他包括Oracle
再加个Oracle
就是Oracle在写在里面
对
然后就是这些大的hyperscale
认知非常超前
但是市场的认知是之后的
华尔街的认知是不喜欢Kapex
因为过去20年了
我们都是喜欢开发软件
在那个Kapex的基础上开发软件
然后可以收税
然后收药费
对吧
你不喜欢工厂
所以当你free cash flow降低之后
华尔街会一直定价
你要降低Kapex
你不降低Kapex公司
固执不行
然后现在我们已经看到
happy kapex的这些公司
这个hyperscale的这些公司
中间包括Google
原来是对于很多的支出
是非常generous
非常手非常花的
非常温和
但是包括Google
包括你看到
他现在做的tpu 运达
包括后面的这些现成的安排
他都变得更加对于成本的追求
因为他清楚了
我们现在模式要做
重磁散投
重磁散投路
我就要把每一块给你算清楚
然后把价格加下来
包括谷歌对于
甚至谷歌你知道谷歌下单
非常想直接去下到台阶线去
当然台阶线不让他想
台阶线让他做Militate
对吧
然后谷歌想把封装
然后给音槽
不给台阶线
为什么呢
因为covers太贵了
我觉得covers太贵是个重要的原因
一方面他要分散一下
他的这个封装的现成
就是封装的风险
但是贵也是一方面
很大一方面原因
所以在这里面
华尔街会森号开始定价
你们这些hyperscale
free cash flow不够
第一个就是
有一种可能会发生
就是中间只要有一个
因为你每一次的增长
你的AI头颅增长
都是超预期
你总有一次不超预期的
因为预期越来越高
你总有一次不超预期
加上你的free cash flow
在变时的时候
总有总会开始不超预期
然后就会开始反过来
对3米的质疑
这个是会杀伤很大
因为现在整个3米的需求
确实
缺过去了28年
然后断货断到28年
然后也需求是贡献大的
你只要有这个质疑
他回头的时候
包括对光膜 宽爱对存储
这些东西
他的调整会很稳
然后这种调整的时候
要坚决的买入
坚决的买入
半导体的需求是
我刚刚讲过的逻辑
它是整个我们过去30年
运行模式的改变
然后第二种可能
就是对于hyperscale的担心
关注一下meta的cds
但是我现在不能确定
这个cds跟他股价下跌
有多大的玩笑
就是meta跟这个业绩不太好
股价下跌
没有到一个非常alarm的阶段
但是meta的cds确实在往上跑
那就是到5月1号的时候
跑了
你说从平均的水平往上跑了
十几个败财
是蛮吓人的
没有变成像alloc当时的状态
但是如果meta被定价成alloc
那alloc cds长了很多
meta被定价成alloc那种状态的话
不要像alloc这么严重
但是只要有这方面的定价
meta很难做出像alloc这样的决策
这个是为什么的
怎么说呢
就是meta虽然zacor决定性也是很强
但是我不觉得他像老larry这样会all in
他会这样all in
然后meta内部还是相对来说温暖一点
所以不光是meta
其实包括一些其他happy scale
因为all on the way
我觉得这件事情发生
可能需要个半年
然后在半年里面
你也不知道比方说macrosoft
说不定变成受害者了
对吧
然后如果说是有这样类似的情况发生的时候
那么大家开始定价这个问题的时候
因为hyperscale包括alloc
他们这些语音
它是相当于说槓桿最高的这个玩家
在这里面
它的真实现金流变整
要到28年以后了
要到28年
也就是现在投入以后产出
更高高的保险公司
或者是干那个电厂一样
他就今天投入以后产出的
所以在这个过程当中
他的cds上升
为限制他
他知道我必须要干这个事
我不买地
玩大风
我就完了
但是你没现金了
你的cds上去了
你不得不放弃的时候
放弃哪怕一点
对市场影响都很大
现在需求
就半导体需求
你不用担心他
他baclok1.5万亿
就baclok就没有完成定单
有一点万亿
但是有前面的这些baclok
定单的这个松动
就是他的这个
投入的这个松动
会引起一些祸化
我觉得这个会是
今年向后面半年
不要说在半年以后
或者那些时候
会发生危险
然后这个危险
会和宏观的危险共振
现在我们看到的
宏观的危险是油价的正统
但是油价哪怕这个问题解决了
油价对后面的通胀的
显性的影响
就是在经济层面需求的影响
就是经济GDP要下降影响
是要半年以后出来的
所以就和收了一个税是一样
你就把它当成收了关税
收了关税以后
它经济的基本面的影响
是半年以后出来的
所以如果这两件事情发生共振的话
我个人觉得一个丧品是
在那个时候会有机会
所以你任何时候
你卖飞都不用跑
这有个人感觉
但是整体的半导体的打扭是
远远没有结束
这个事情我们已经讲了一年多了
不止一年
一直在讲这个事情
好吧
今天我可能多说了加尽十分钟
我就先不放Q&A了
谢谢大家的时间